okay so we can see your
uh screen okay so uh let's start the
session
um so this is the session on graph
algorithms
uh and uh we are going to keep the talk
as usual to eight minutes each
and unless they're clarifying questions
let's just keep it uh
for the end of the session at where at
which point we can ask
uh questions to the speakers as well as
have a panel discussion
okay so to get us started the first
speaker is obi maya who is going to tell
us about
uh graphs um comparison graphs as a
unified method for
uniformity testing okay so can you hear
me all right
yes okay and i'll give you a warning uh
about a minute
before the end of your talk and like
before eight minutes i'll give you a
warning at seven minutes
okay so hi everyone my name is
a graduate student at the university and
i'm going to talk about comparison
graphs
so let me give you some background the
problem we consider is uniformity
testing the problem in property testing
and test subject is a distribution d
over a domain size
n and the inputs we're going to get is q
independent
samples from the distribution d and our
task is to distinguish between two cases
one is that we have the uniform
distribution over the entire domain
and the other that we have distribution
that is epsilon far say in l1 distance
from the uniform distribution okay so
our parameter the domain size n
and the proximity parameter epsilon
and the problem was already solved like
10 years ago we know that
square root of n over epsilon squared is
the right sample complexity for that the
amount of samples are necessary and
sufficient to solve that
okay so this is a brief history the
problem was first considered by the two
for no ruben phil smith and white in fox
2000 and implicitly by golovkin one bit
earlier a bit earlier
and their days count is counting
collisions and the result they show
is that the sample complexity is between
square root of n and square of n over
epsilon to the fourth
so the dependency on n was uh quite
clear but the dependency on epsilon
remained
a mystery for quite some time roughly 10
years
later it was solved by paninski and it
showed that its dependency on epsilon is
one over epsilon squared and it had a
small caveat that was
fixed by centiaconicolas valiant in
valiant a bit
after and another paper that i want to
mention is a paper by diacon nicolas
leaky spiegelson price from 2016 that
actually shows the original idea
of counting collisions it can be made
optimal so with optimal analysis it can
actually succeed with square root of n
over epsilon squared samples
okay so what is the idea of the original
tester
and is by golden helen so we have this
magnitude called the collision
probability of a distribution this is
basically
the chance of two independent samples
having the same value
and we know that if we consider all
distributions over domain size
n and then the one to minimize it is the
uniform distribution over the entire
domain
but a more interesting a little bit more
interesting facts
is that any distribution that is epsilon
far actually has a noticeably higher
collision probability
okay and we're going to use this gap in
order to test uniformity
so our idea is going to be to estimate
the collision probability
and to say yes to say uniform if it is
low and to say not uniformly
it is high so how are we going to
estimate the collision probability the
basic
idea is that if we draw two samples and
compare them then
well the the they will be the same
with exactly the collision probability
so this indicator actually has the right
expectation but of course it doesn't
have it doesn't concentrate well because
this is only one indicator
if we take a bunch of samples and make a
bunch of comparisons
then actually we get a good
concentration so this is the statistic
that we take
and we count the collisions among q
samples and we normalize by the number
of comparison which is q choose 2.
let me just say that these indicators
are not independent
and this is kind of the problem the
reason why the first original analysis
wasn't optimal so this is a bit tricky
the dependencies create some problems
okay so let me give you some motivation
for this uh
so for our results and lately testing
was considered under many constraints
um in many many models so started
roughly three years ago
as far as i know there's been a whole
bunch of work on that
and what motivates us is that under
constraints original tester
uh counting all the collisions among
samples among
uh batch of samples is irrelevant this
kind of makes us
a bit sad so our idea is to generalize
this
this tester the collision based tester
we do it as follows
so here's a new definition we call a
comparison graph
and the idea is this we we refer to all
of our samples as a bunch of
vertices in the graph and each edge in
the graph is a comparison
a pair of samples that we actually
compare
so now we have a collision indicator
such as before
for each edge in the graph in the
comparison graph
and the new statistic is going to sum
the collision so to count collisions
only between pairs of samples that are
indicated by the comparison graph
so we sum these indicators only over the
edges of the graph the pairs of samples
indicated by the graph
and of course we normalize by the number
of comparisons
we've made and this should estimate the
collision probability so again if this
is
loads and we say uniform and if it's
high we say not uniform
okay so let's see some examples of the
duality between
a collision-based tester that is induced
by a graph
so the original tester is to compare all
the pairs of samples
so this is basically a click graph
another another possibility is to divide
all our pairs into two batches and count
collisions only between the two
different batches
this would be actually represented by a
complete bipartite graph
another possibility is to say this the
entire
dependencies that we said that this
click creates and to draw
a completely new pair for each
comparison that we make
and this would be like a perfect
matching
okay so i hope this gives you some
notion of the duality between comparison
graph
and collision based testers that they
induce
so here's our first structural result
a comparison graph induces a good an
epsilon uniformity tester
if it holds if two conditions hold
and let me just remind you that an
epsilon uniformity tester distinguishes
between the cases that were uniform
over the entire domain of size m and the
case that we're epsilon five in l1
distance
okay so the two uh the two conditions
that the comparison
graph must hold is that it makes enough
comparison so the number of edges should
be
a large enough as a function of n and
epsilon
but also that it creates relatively few
dependencies
so dependencies here as we said before
dependencies
are quantified by two paths in the graph
so
each time we have two comparisons the
cherished sample this created two paths
and these are bad for us they they hire
they increase our variance and they make
the concentration
not as good and this is bad for us
is left okay
so this is the idea and in particular um
if we look at the click graph then
whenever this is the size of the click
then those two conditions hold okay so
let's see
uh the how we use this to create
uniformity testers under constraints so
this is the generic recipe
we have the test requirements and we
have the constraints by the model
we also have a complexity measure which
might vary from
model to model and we basically want to
translate all of these to graph
notations
okay to understand to to some
constraints or maybe
the values that we want to optimize the
measure is the values we want to
optimize
or the comparison graph so we use
theorem one in order to
translate the requirements of the tester
to the graph constraint this is exactly
the server and that we said we need some
structure on the comparison graph
and we will need to use some heuristic
to that our model dependent to
understand the other
two but once we have everything in the
language of graphs we simply need to
choose the right comparison graph and
simulate the tester
that it induces in the um in the model
so let me give you one example probably
won't manage to do two
one example is that we have a
simultaneous model so we have
k players each of them get q samples
and they can only send a short message
to the referee
but they cannot interact with one
another so this is the constraint of the
model and we count how many samples per
player
are required so as before this theorem
tells us that we have this uh
this constraint on the on the graph but
also since we have k players that can't
interact then the graph
it represents the entire set of samples
and it's actually made of k disjoint
sub graph each subgraph is a set of
samples of
this office single player and the sample
popular well this is the number of nodes
in each sub graph
if we take all of this and mesh them up
together then it's quite clear that
each player need to take q samples and
compare
all of them together and only send the
number of
collision itself to the referee so this
is a small
calculation that i'm going to see let me
just
say what is the streaming model so in
the streaming model we have the samples
come as a stream
and we only process one sample at a time
but we can store up to m
samples and we have this cute lemon that
says
that this also gives some uh some
constraint on the graph the average
degree of the comparison graph cannot be
too high
and it's quite uh it's quite surprising
that
the best comparison graph for this model
is also the same graph as before only
with different
parameters of course regarding to the
model
so let me just sum up real quick we
generalize the notion of collision
based tester using the definition of
comparison graph
which the edge where the edges simply
indicate which collision which
comparison we're going to make
and we showed some generic recipe for
uniformity testing under constraints
and it actually induces optimal or near
optimal results in several known models
and we hope that it can also help
devise more testers for uniformity
testers
for informative testing in other models
um so
that's it thank you sorry for going over
here
noise uh thanks away so uh let's go over
to the next speaker
uh okay yeah so next speaker
is uh j martia hi uh
should i begin okay i so uh yeah sergio
is going to tell us about
the gap between uh or maybe there's no
gap between the detection and the
recovery complexity of planted leak okay
check out it
yeah uh thanks india so uh i'm jaya
mardia
and let's just dive in uh let me start
by telling you a little bit about the
planetary problem
uh it's a problem on a graph with n
vertices under the second parameter k
which you want to care about is the size
of the planetary clique but don't worry
about the details
and there are two variants of this
problem the detection variant and the
recovery variant
i want you to think of k as being some
sort of a signal to noise ratio because
this is a statistical problem and as k
becomes larger the problem becomes
easier
in fact if k is larger than 2 log n then
we know the
information theoretically both the
detection and the recovery variants are
solvable that's great however
we only know of polynomial time
algorithms to solve these problems if k
is much
much larger on the order of square root
of n
and in fact decades of research has
solidified the belief that
this this is indeed the best we can do
and there is an exponential gap between
the signal to noise ratios at which
this problem is statistically versus
computationally tractable
this sort of a gap called a stat comp
gap is
believed to exist for a wide variety of
problems not just this one
on the previous slide one thing that was
implicit was that we equated
computational efficiency with the
existence of polynomial time algorithms
i'm sure i don't need to justify this i
think most everyone here will believe
that that's a reasonable thing to do
and the study of statcom gaps has also
taken this perspective
however we know that there are other
useful notions of complexity
they consider other resources that are
different from time
and also studying them somehow sometimes
gives surprising insights for example
the space complexity
turns out to be related to the
complexity of two-player games
communication complexity turns out to
have connections in understanding
streaming complexity
so studying these can be surprising
further perhaps implicitly the study of
the statcom gaps implicitly already
knows this
the evidence for the planetary
conjecture that i told you about on the
previous slide
has built up by studying restricted
algorithmic classes
and showing that these restricted
classes can't solve the problem below
the square root and threshold
if we squint a little at these uh these
things which study the levels of a
convex hierarchy
or the degree of polynomials required to
compute certain things
we can imagine that they're studying
non-standard notions of resource or
complexity
and so implicitly
in the statistical context these
non-standard alternative notions of
complexity already are being studied
and so the point of this slide is just
to try and convince you that maybe we
should explicitly start studying these
and if we do then at least i think the
first thing we should
try and do is see if this stat comp gap
that existed
uh still exists what if it disappears
what if
the location at which these thresholds
appear change dramatically
so basically what i'm asking is are
these
statcom gaps fundamentally the problem
or do they depend
quite heavily on the notion of
computational efficiency that we are
giving them through obviously these are
very broad questions
uh and in this work we don't answer any
of them
we just look at one specific uh notion
of
alternative complexity and one specific
problem and try to see what happens when
we put them together
and so what you want to do is see if the
statcom phenomena that we know and love
for the planetary problem
also hold when we use the length of
space complexity
okay and what are these phenomena i
already mentioned that there is this
statistical computational gap that
exists
and what i haven't told you so far but
is true is that the detection and the
recovery variants of this problem
have the same complexity at least when
we view it through the length of
polynomial time algorithms existing or
not
it's the exact same threshold at which
polynomial time a singletonized ratio
threshold
at which polynomial time algorithms
begin to work and so our hope is that
even for space complexity this sort of
phenomena holds
uh just so we're on the same page by a
space efficient algorithm
uh we mean an algorithm that takes
roughly o of log n bits of space
or working space or scratch paper
okay uh what are some easy to see facts
about the phase complexity of this
problem
in fact if we simply analyze existing
algorithms for this problem it's very
easy to see that
detection can be solved efficiently or
in o of log n bits of space
as soon as k is larger than the square
root and threshold this is exactly what
we wanted
and so far things are great however
all of the existing algorithms for
recovery seem to require polynomial
amounts of space
and so the question here is is there
actually a log space algorithm to
recover planted leaks of size larger
than
omega of root n if we can come up with
such an algorithm the nice thing is that
the conjectured time complexity-based
gap at this threshold would also hold
for space complexity at the same
threshold
and even for space complexity we would
know that detection and recovery
are the same for this problem they
behave essentially identically
what this would do is this uh threshold
signal to noise ratio of omega to 10
would now we we would believe it is
indeed fundamental to the problem with
robust changes in our notion of
efficiency and it's reversed to changes
in like what formulation we use
detection or recovery
so this is why we want a log space
algorithm for this problem
uh so this is what we're aiming for and
the main result of this work
thus it does not give us what we want
but it comes
fairly close what we can do is uh design
an algorithm that has this ugly looking
space complexity bound
the log star function is extremely
slowly growing function
and just so we can understand this bound
a bit better let's look at
some examples if the signal to noise
ratio
click size k is just slightly larger
than square root n
i think those are nine logs stacked on
top of each other
nine is arbitrary it could be any
constant number of logs stacked on top
of each other
if this was the click size then the
space complexity of this algorithm would
indeed be
two of log inputs which is exactly what
we wanted
however if we really do go down to the
square root n threshold
precisely there then the space
complexity is log star n
times log n which isn't exactly where
you want it to be it's slightly off
however it is really close and what it
does is suggest that a log space
algorithm that we want
exists and hence maybe
uh the the phenomena that we want for
space complexity also
hold i'll end by just mentioning a
couple of open problems
the first is the obvious one is there a
log space algorithm for this problem
uh at the root and threshold
and the second there's a more vague and
open-ended open problem
which is uh we wanted to study the
notions of uh
we wanted to study the statcom phenomena
for uh
our various problems uh for with
alternative notions of complexity
but we here we've done this only for one
specific problem one specific
alternative notion of complexity
it would be very annoying to have to do
this for every single problem where we
already know
the statcom gap so is there a more
generic way in which we can study
a large classes of these problems
i have a few seconds so i'll just plug
uh
on the slack channel corresponding to
this paper i have
a poll uh and you yes you can go and
find whether you think that this log
space algorithm actually exists or not
and yeah thank you
thank you uh yeah uh
so maybe and and will you uh and after
the opinion poll is done would you tell
us about a new result which
achieves the log space algorithm yeah i
think democracy will
prevail and then we don't need to prove
anything right okay
okay thank you so next up is pascal who
is going to tell us about
finding hamiltonian cycles with high
probability
uh surpassing
all right so i'll jump right in hello
everyone thanks for
coming my name is pascal zu i'm from
intege zurich and this is joint work
with
um raikkonen and olof and i'm the cash
taker
so this is uh session on graph
algorithms so i probably shouldn't
decline too much on graphs
but just for completeness so we know a
hamilton cycle is a cycle which
visits every vertex in a in a graph and
to find hamilton cycles and graphs this
is generally viewed as a rather hard
problem so this is a
np-hard problem and it would be very
surprising if we find a polynomial time
algorithm for this kind of problem
so in general we know this problem is
hard but is it
also hard in very specific cases and the
answer is of course no already very
early we had drock's theorem which told
us that
if the minimum degree is n over two in
any graph then we can find a hamilton
unit cycle
so intuitively if the vertices have a
lot of edges then well surely there is
some substructure there
and the proof of this theorem this works
via poser rotations
you might be familiar with them the idea
is if we have a path
and we have an edge going back to the
pass then we can replace
um the corresponding edge in the path
to get a new end point of the path so we
have a path with the same vertices
but a different endpoint and this allows
us to
let's say search for a continuation of
the path for a very long time
and um with this method for example uh
drx theorem can be proven
okay so let me talk more about random
graphs
um we have the ren erdogan random graph
model which
um you might be familiar with this is a
graph on n vertices where
every edge is present with probability p
independently
so um if we look at d rock's theorem we
immediately see
okay if we have a gn one half a little
bit more than one half
simply by concentration bounds okay this
graph must be hamiltonian
because every vertex has degree at least
um
n over two right so then the question is
naturally
is this the best we can do and um
it is not for random graphs this is a
very well studied problem
and we know even even the lower order
terms for which
which are needed such that gnp is
uh hamiltonian so this is roughly
p which is log n over n so as soon as we
have
um on average log n many edges we should
have a hamilton cycle in our graph
and um this threshold coincides with the
minimum degree two
so as soon as gnp has minimal degree two
we also expect it to have a hamilton
cycle
and of course not any sooner because as
long as there is a edge with only one
edge
sorry a vertex with only one edge um
this this vertex cannot be part of the
cycle
okay and and this is kind of part of the
intuition that says that randomness
really helps a lot
in in with the expansion properties to
find these hamilton cycles
and there is a lot of existing work on
this um
that that kind of proves that in random
graphs that
hamilton cycles is are our
presence not just a few but a few but
a lot of them as soon as we have at
least one
and taking this uh intuition maybe we
can build an algorithm
so we cannot hope for an algorithm in
the general case that
can find the hamilton cycle in any graph
but maybe we can find a hamilton cycle
in most graphs or at least in a random
graph
so maybe let me give you a quick
overview on what has been done so
far this is just a short outtake by no
means is this complete
so the first three results maybe you can
see that
the focus was on improving the
p at which we could find hamilton cycles
unless the run time
but the runtime was always polynomial
which is significant for the
p versus np question and in the later
three
these results were actually done in the
adjacency matrix model
and there this time here is optimal but
the p is by no means near this threshold
yet
so um there was still some work to do
and this is where we would like to
improve upon this
so we would like to go in linear time at
least
at the same p that the first algorithm
here the unlearned invalid
algorithm was working at
so let me give you a bit of an intuition
how our algorithm works or let me
actually start
with the original algorithm by anglian
and valiant
because i said that in random graphs we
have so much structure we have a lot of
expansions
we can find hamilton a lot of hamilton
cycles
and the first intuition is just we want
to do a random walk
so if i start from any vertex i can
query a next edge
at random and then with high probability
i'll get some new edge which is
currently unvisited
and i'll do this for a while and you can
see as long as
my pass is very short uh the number of
vertices which are
are still used is very small and the
number of unused vertices is very large
so with some constant number of new
queries i can just
increase the length of my pass
so i can do this for a while and at some
point my path will cover most of the
vertices
and then there comes a problem that
i might need to query a lot of new edges
at the single vertex
and this might not be good because a
random graph will on average only have
log and many neighbors
so what i can do here is implicitly do
the poster rotations i mentioned at the
beginning so if i
query new edge then if i'm going back
into the pass
i ignore the edge if the distance to the
current vertex is less than n over two
and if it's more then i can detach the
cycle
in this way and
and then i get a new starting point from
which i can try to continue my pass
if at some point i find an edge back to
the cycle i can reincorporate the cycle
into my
into my path and this way i mean if i'm
a bit lucky then hopefully this random
walk will
um find all the unused vertices and
eventually
um give me a hamilton cycle
but as you could see towards the end
most of the vertices are already used
so the probability of finding a new
vertex is
very small and this is going to be the
bottleneck and this is where we
will actually improve upon the original
algorithm
so if we do a short analysis of this
what we do is just we query random edges
so the probability of finding an
unused vertex is exactly the number of
unused vertices divided by
the total number of vertices so this is
equivalent to the coupon collector
problem
and um there's a bit of a technical
detail why there's an additional log
factor
namely to store the pass and do these
postal rotation we need a data structure
which accumulates an additional log n
factor so
this was the original algorithm by
angling and valiant
and
and the runtime of this was n log
squared n right so we try to shave off
these two logs
log factors with um with a neat trick
and maybe this can be helpful also for
other algorithms which need to speed up
down to the optimal runtime so
the first thing that we do uh yeah we
have a minute left
okay thank you um the first thing that
we do is instead of
um because i said there's this technical
detail of poster rotations
um the first thing that we do is we look
for a matching instead of a
hamilton pass and the reason for this is
if in the matching
we replace edges this
is a local change and we do not need to
change anything on the other
edges and as we can see here the local
change does not affect the other edges
so it can be stored in constant time
and the second part that we want to
improve was
that towards the end of this matching
that we had we kept on having less
probability of actually finding
so um so i'm gonna skip ahead a bit
so at the beginning it should be easy to
find new new edges because
we choose random new neighbors and these
should not be used yet
but towards the end the target set might
shrink a lot
so what we do is expose a neighborhood
of this target set
like this and then any neighbor of the
of the target set any match neighbor to
these vertices
is also a good neighbor because we can
then replace
two edges one edge with two edges
so what does this mean um if we
search for a new matching edge from uh
from vertex and b
then we have now the we could match the
target set which is of course good
but we can also match to these neighbors
of the dna of the neighborhood of this
target set
and then um replace the blue edge here
with an
orange and and well with two orange
edges
and in this way also increase our
matching and the problem and if as long
as this neighborhood is large enough
then we guarantee that the probability
is big enough
to um to finish quickly
okay and um there are some technical
details
to uh if we get to two perfect matchings
we get a bunch of cycles
and these cycles can then um be stitched
together to a hamilton cycle
in reasonably fast time so to keep the
whole algorithm linear
and right so this is what what our work
was
and i'm sorry that had to speed up a bit
at the end if you want a
closer look at the algorithm take maybe
a look at the
the longer talk or at the paper that we
published
thank you um thank you
so next up is guppy nut uh mishra who's
going to
tell us about streaming models so uh
lastly i think if this stops
statistical institution i will talk
about even the easiest grapple learning
problem
is not easy in streaming this is a joint
work with
bhattacharya originally in this paper we
consider
a simple variant of classical graph
coloring problem in streaming model
the problem we name it as conflict
estimation problem
where we have two inputs the graph g
itself and
a coloring function f on the vertices of
the graph
the objective of us is to estimate the
number of monochromatic edges
in the input graph with respect to the
given coloring function h
first observe that this conflict
estimation problem is very easy in
classical ram model
also note that this is the problem uh
we consider it this is the problem who's
a easier variant
a further simple variant we consider we
use to prove that
the classical graph coloring problem is
in np
in this chapter we study this so called
easy
graph coloring problem in gram model in
different vertex arrival streams
now let us have a brief discussion what
are different vertex arrival streams
in the basic vertex arrival streams the
vertices of the graph
is exposed in an arbitrary order and for
us
also with their colors
when a vertex v is exposed we also get
to know
all of its neighbors that are in the p
exposed vertex
vertex arrival with degree oracle in
short va deg model
is same as that of vortex arrival model
but
we also get to know about the degree of
the vertex b
when b is exposed
there is another vertex survivor model
called vertex arrival in random order
model and random order
in vram is it is same
same as basic vertex arrival model but
the ordering in which the vertices are
are coming say b 1 to b n corresponds to
a random permutation of 1 to n
this is our set of results
we study the conflict estimation problem
where our objective is to estimate the
number of monochromatic edges
in all three vertex arrival models in
this slide
n denotes the number of vertices am
denotes the number of edges
and the capital t denotes a promise
on the lower bound on the number of
monochromatic edges
note that in va and va deg model
the upper bound on lower bound is tight
and the space complexity for conflict
distribution
in random order vertex arrival model is
better than
that of other two also
note that there is a gap between upper
and lower bound
in case of uh random order vertical
survival model which we which again i
will discuss
around the end of the top
also i would like to note that our main
technical contribution in this paper
is is upper and lower bound in case of
random order vertex survival model which
i will present in this talk
so let us first discuss uh the
i the proof sketch of our upper bound
result for conflict estimation in
random order vertex level model first
observe that
the number of monochromatic edges in g
with respect to
f is half of sum of monochromatic
degrees
of all the vertices
our idea in a high level is to pick a
random
subset of vertices r of desired size
say n by root t and note that
this arc r for us is fast
n by root t vertices in this stream
because
now we are discussing about random order
steps
the idea is to examine the neighbor of
monochrome
uh coping as we can't hear you
plays a very important role in the
design analysis
first of all that last 30 seconds got
cut off so maybe
you can go back for the last 30 seconds
there you
yes so shall i repeat this slide
yes yeah yeah yeah this slide yeah can
please repeat this like
yes so what's the previous slide okay
yes yes the previous light was okay this
one the the okay
so our idea in a high level
set r also
the main idea is to examine the
neighborhood of every vertex
the monochromatic neighborhood of every
vertex in this randomly selected set
r so the quantity
kappa b which is the number of
monochromatic neighbors
b has inside this state r we call it as
projected monogrammatic degree of b play
a very crucial role
in design and analysis operator
and the main observation is this
quantity kappa v
can be computed in this stream in the
vortex arrival stream
because uh
the set r is the first set of uh first
set of environment vertices
we start the algorithm by storing the
colors of
all the vertices in the set r and we are
considering
vertex arrival string so the projected
monochromatic degree
of any desired vertex b can be computed
in this industry
now let us have another observation
consider a vertex
having large monochromatic degree
observe that
the projected monochromatic degree kappa
v is good enough
to estimate the monochromatic degree of
the vertex v
as monogrammatic degree is large in this
case
but note that the challenge is how can
we decide a vertex is having high
monochromatic degree because we are
we are seeing the graph in a straight
streaming person
graph as the coloring in the streaming
question so we cannot
know whether the whether the vertex is
having large monogrammatic degree for
all the vertices
so to cope up with this our idea is to
classify the vertices as high
or low depending on the value of
projected monochromatic degrees that is
kappa base
and this can be done because
we have already discussed this kappa b
quantity capabilities that is
projected monogrammatic degrees can be
computed over
random order vertex arrival stream
so our idea is to classify the vertex
set of the graph
into two parts namely capital h and
capital l
where h did not set up all high vertices
and l will not set up all low vertices
uh and break the sum of monochromatic
degrees into two parts
it is some due to all high vertices and
the second part
is strong due to all low vertices and we
will be done by discussing
how to approximate mh and ml name
so i'll try to type up the in a minute
try to wrap up in a minute
yes so this is the uh this is our idea
to approximate both
mh and ml
[Music]
individually so we have already briefly
discussed discussed about
how to approximate the quantity image
by classifying depending on the value of
projected monochromatic degree
and for to approximate the low vertices
uh
the projected monochromatic is only good
enough that's why
we apply a rocketing technique where
estimating the size of
large buckets will be good enough and
as we are considering vertex arrival
stream
and we are storing all the vertices as
well as colors of
all the vertices are we can compute we
can
also estimate the sizes of the large
market
and the space complexity is dominated by
the size of
r which is roughly n by root t and here
i would like to note that
we also prove a lower bound uh
n by root t n by t square which is not
tight
by reducing from a variant of multiparty
set digitalness
um however we believe that our upper
bound is in fact tight
we don't have a proof thank you everyone
for listening to the
um thank you uh so uh
the last speaker is nitin
so uh listen if you can share your
slides please
my screen ah yes you can okay
here you go uh hi i'm nathan verma i'm a
post doc at the university of fifa
and today i will speak about erasure
resilient sublinear time graph
algorithms
the goal of our paper is to model and
investigate subliminal algorithms that
run on graphs with incomplete
information
usually in the case of sublinative
algorithms for graphs the assumption
is that you have query or sample access
to graphs and
this is not realistic in many scenarios
for example consider the case of a
social network
where vertices are users and edges
denote the friendship relations
and for privacy some users could decide
to hide
their edges and we get a partially
erased crop
such partially erased graphs could be
represented as
adjacency less model where there are
erased
entries erased adjacency interest
specifically
and for a constant alpha a graph is
alpha erased if
at most alpha fraction of the entries in
the adjacency lists are
adversarially erased a completion
of such a partially erased
representation is a valid graph
obtained by filling in these erased
entries
this is an adaptation of the erasure
resilient model for
function property testing to the case of
graphs
now an erasure resilient graph algorithm
gets a parameter
alpha and query access to an alpha
erased graph
it can make two kinds of queries it can
specify a vertex and ask for its degree
it can also specify a vertex and an
integer i
and obtain the ith entry in the
adjacency list of v
and this entry could be erased for
example
the performance of algorithms are
analyzed in the worst case over
all alpha erased graphs and
we study two important computational
tasks
that of graph property testing and that
of estimating
graph parameters uh in the context of
graph property testing
our model can be seen as a
generalization the general graph model
of pronus and rom
which is in turn a generalization of the
boundary degree graph model of gold
recondrome
in particular we study to the properties
in
problems of testing connectedness and
estimating the average degree
so this is uh the kind of schema of the
problem of erasure resilient testing
connectedness
there is an algorithm called the tester
that receives two parameters alpha and
epsilon
it has query access or oracle access to
an alpha based graph
and the requirement is that the
algorithm has to say
accept with probability at least two
thirds if there exists a completion
of this graph that is connected it has
to say reject with probability at least
two-thirds
if for every completion you need to add
at least
epsilon m edges to make it connected and
in this case we say the graph is epsilon
far
from connected now this is a much more
this is a meta definition
and this can be generalized to other
properties also
in the special case of no erasures
connectedness testing has already been
studied
and the prior best tester has very
complexity one over epsilon d square
where b is the average degree and here
are our results
we say that connectedness testing is not
so
easy always specifically when
the fraction of erasures is more than a
threshold here the threshold is the
proximity parameter
we say that connectedness testing
requires a number of queries
linear in the input representation
on the other hand we say that if alpha
is
smaller than this threshold then we can
test connectedness
in using number of queries independent
of the length of the input
representation
further we show that if alpha is even
smaller than epsilon over 2
we can further improve the query
complexity
so these are the somehow like big things
that
like at a high level we show a phase
transition uh that
and there is a fraction of erasures um
above which connectedness testing
requires linearly many queries and below
connectedness testing can be done in
constant
any queries uh in the special case of no
erasures
the complexity of a tester is better
than that of the pri best prior upper
bound
for this really well studied problem and
our upper bound is also tight as we
show in a later work
for average degree this also has been
well studied
and specifically pi showed that
one can obtain a two plus epsilon
approximation algorithm
by making only root and degree queries
and he also showed that to get something
better
using only degree queries you need omega
n very complexity
now uh in a sequence of work gold
rahital and eden natal showed that
one can obtain a one plus epsilon
approximation algorithm
that makes roughly root in degree and
uniformly random neighbor queries and
this is what we show
we show that estimating average degree
of alpha arrays graphs
uh can be done with approximation ratio
1 plus epsilon plus 2 alpha
using very complexity rootin and we show
that this
presence of alpha here is in some sense
necessary that if you want to get
like one plus gamma approximation for
gamma less than alpha
you need to make at least omega n
queries
and our model can be seen as an
interpolation
or unification of the model with only
degree queries and the model
with both degree and neighbor queries
specifically when alpha is small or say
zero we have access to both degree and
neighbor queries
and as adjacency list entries get
progressively erased
uh you can see view this as like losing
access to some of the
neighbor queries and you are in the
model by pygame
so here are a bunch of open problems so
we saw that there is a phase transition
in the testing connectedness now
there is also somehow a secondary phase
transition much softer
around alpha is equal to epsilon over 2
is that inherent by any chance
now a property a graph property is
monotone if it is preserved under
deletion of edges and vertices
and it's a large class of properties and
we observe that if
there is a bound on the vertex degree
then
one can obtain a ratio resilience in
this adjacency less model by paying
only d square in the query complexity
we ask um like what is the cost of
obtaining a ratio resilience um for
testing monotone properties for general
graphs which is what we've been
considering in this paper
uh our model for
formation of erasures is quite general
in the sense that
uh a vertex v can be raised uh by an
adversary from the adjacency list of u
but u can still be present in the
adjacency list of v
we ask whether testing can become easier
if one assumes that erasures are somehow
made symmetrically
in the sense if v is arrays from use
list then u
also is erased from this list this is a
assumption and can this assumption make
life
easier
and like we also this
this is another interesting question the
relationship between erasure resilient
and tolerant testing of graphs
roughly speaking a tolerant tester for a
property must distinguish with high
probability
between inputs that are somehow close to
satisfying property and inputs that are
far from satisfying property
and dikshitar who introduced the irish
resilient function property testing
model
showed that for testing properties of
functions
a tolerant tester implies an erasure
resilient tester
up to some parameters and that technique
actually does not work for the case of
graphs
and so for the case of graphs this
relationship is
somehow much more unknown so what is
really the relationship between
having erasures in the graph versus
having maybe
wrong entries in the adjacency ls or
rather what is the relationship between
the ratio resilient and tolerant testing
in the general drop model
so lots of open questions and um thank
you
thank you and thank you to all the
speakers in the session
so uh we ran a little over time within
the session but that was good so
uh now let's i mean um the idea is to
have have a panel disc have a open
discussion
if there any questions from the audience
uh
we can start with those otherwise i have
some questions
you can if you're a panelist you can
just unmute yourself and ask a question
and otherwise if you you can just
message a question
[Music]
okay if not then let me get started let
me let me answer questions my
first question was to uh actually about
uh the uniformity tester so
um you you proposed a unified analysis
based on compare these conflict graphs
uh do you think there might be something
along the same lines for a general
problem for identity testing
oh yes great question um
so basically i didn't say this because
it was short presentation but identity
testing can be reduced to uniformity
testing so
all of our results apply for uniform so
for identity testing as well
okay a great question for this short
talk
okay excellent uh okay
uh uh another uh so and uh another ques
another question okay so
maybe maybe i can i can i mean i can
just go over to
each of one question first of all
other some other papers and then we'll
see how much time we have
so uh i had another question actually
about the last presentation nathan
so uh yeah i guess in the dense graph
model
we know of good like you know these kind
of some
universal results somehow for noisy for
tolerant property testing right
uh with the evasion noise i guess could
one potentially hope for
even more general results given somehow
the aviation noise is a little
in the dense graph model given it's even
somehow
weaker than like you know uh adversarial
corruption
noise ah in the dense graph models of
uh so erasures are slightly less
problematic i would say
than the adjacency lists model uh
because it's it's a functional
representation
and this already falls under the purview
of um like the
function property testing a model the
ratio model that we defined
and um again so tolerant tester would
imply a ratio resilient with tester with
comparable complexity
if you encounter an erasure you can um
well there is a question of consistency
um but
okay there is there is a mild assumption
here that i'm maybe assuming that i have
access to one half of my adjacency
matrix um
like but more or less um you can just
substitute this erasure with like a zero
and and this is okay okay okay yeah i
was i was seeing more along the lines of
these results to say there's a that have
isn't that this result that uh if a
graph is a hereditary property for
heavy-duty properties can be tested with
constant query complexity even under
noise or
something like that right i was
wondering if like you know they have
such universal
theorems um they will apply for
yeah i think they should apply for
erasure resident testimony okay
okay uh
are there are there any other questions
from any of the panelists any of the
audience i
uh maybe i can also ask the question to
the last speaker
um so did i get this correctly you
assume that the adjacency lists were
like
permuted randomly
not randomly adversarially erased some
entries were adversarially raised some
adversary before the algorithm interacts
with the graph some adversity comes and
erases an alpha fraction of
the entries arbitrary entries ah but but
the adjacency list like
are the entries like sorted or is the
adversary also allowed to
sort like the non-erased entries
so adversary has no control over the
ordering of
adjacency entries and we do not assume
anything about the ordering of
adjacency entries as well so
so in a sense you're also assuming that
it's adverse here right if you don't
assume anything
right right would it help in any way
that it sort or does the problem become
trivial if it's sorted in any way
no i don't think so no but it could help
it could help but i i do not think the
problem at least the connectedness no i
don't think it would become trivial
but there could be problems that might
become trivial but
yeah not the problems that we are
considering
good good christmas thank you
uh any uh i mean i have another okay
sorry there's
a uh okay i can
uh okay sean has a question uh
to jay that is it known that
there is a randomized algorithm that
finds the planted clique in log space
it seems to me that not de-randomization
would be non-trivial even in the
random graph case i i guess he's asking
about a random
uh random graph setting uh
maybe i can uh let me see uh actually
sorry uh
basically my question is it seems like
my understanding is this algorithm is
deterministic
uh and it finds it in whatever login
logs are in yeah
but i'm wondering like is it possible
that there could exist
like a a rand like if you're allowed
arbitrary randomness could you find a
log space algorithm yeah
it's a good question uh i i
when i was looking for a system
algorithm i didn't restrict myself to
deterministic algorithms i was very
happy to use randomness if it helped
i couldn't find the way to use it
helpfully but
you're definitely right it might be a
good avenue to try and see you can use
some techniques that necessarily need
time
okay cool thank you i mean generally
also like you know
i guess i mean this doesn't have any
bearing on the question you asked but
this gap that is there between a
potential randomized
deterministic potential speed up
obtained due to randomization
i guess it's really tiny for any
de-randomization kind of things to work
really
so yeah i guess that yeah it doesn't
have any bearing on the question really
i mean
uh but uh yeah uh i i guess i
also actually i mean it's a good time we
can have this discussion continue we can
continue this discussion but it's a good
time to remind everyone
that the other session is starting as
well so in a couple of minutes so
if you want to go there and miss this
exciting discussion
um uh okay so actually i also had
another question
uh for jay so um you
talked about the statistical
computational gaps i guess planted creek
is a
is an instantiation of the denser
subgraph problem
uh uh or like you know one can think
about like you know problems where even
like you know we
know tight upper and lower bounds like
stochastic block model so there isn't
really like
per se like at that level for just for
the vanilla stochastic block model
there isn't a gap but i was just
wondering if you have thought about like
you know more
general versions of general questions
like these yeah so
i haven't explicitly thought about them
for too long uh but let me
address the two examples you did give so
i think even for the student
for the stochastic block model i think
when there are more communities like
some sort of a gap and even just when
there isn't a gap you could
ask the question okay we have polynomial
time algorithms do we have log space
algorithms
without explicitly thinking about this
too hard i think
that they should be they should follow
fairly easily uh because
there are spectral algorithms and uh
this
in the stochastic model the input graph
is sparse and so
uh you should be able to do some sort of
uh
local walk and some of the
the real struggle with in the planetary
problem with getting down
getting the complexity down from log
square n bits
uh to log n bits is that uh the graph
we're
concerned with is not sparse so i i
expect that for sparse graphs it should
be fine but
don't hold me did i actually actually
uh on that note so when you say you have
a
so you should have asked us during the
talk when you say you have a lock space
algorithm you just mean that
you will i ident you will output the
identity of one vertex after another
in logarithmic space like some sort of a
okay good question i
there wasn't enough time for me to
specify the details but the
tradition in any space bounded
computation uh
framework is uh we only count the sort
of working space against our test
and uh the input is provided like on a
read-only
uh piece of paper and the output is on a
right-only piece of paper and that way
you can output
large things and that's kind of funny
good so you say okay okay so standard
complexity model up there is a work tape
but the output tape you're not going to
count you cannot generally write okay
great
uh so along those lines maybe one more
question really
actually sorry i should i should let
others ask questions if there are other
questions
i have a question for jay oh okay
uh so what other problems um like
other than like planted click recovery
detection what are the problems where
you see this like stat comp
gap and you can explore for other
computational
resources i think an india mentioned
something called the densest sub graph
problem
uh i think uh
the densest suburb problem is hard for
me to keep in my head because there are
too many parameters to keep straight but
i think for certain parameter regimes
there is
some sort of a stat count gap
and the other problems are things like
sparse principle component analysis
tensor principle component analysis
uh and yeah these sorts of statistical
problems where
you also want to impose sparsity these
sorts of problems somehow
seem to have statcom caps
if you if you want to see the entire web
i would recommend looking at this paper
by
uh brennan and pressler from mit and
yeah they sort of find a new nice web of
reductions between
various problems okay thank you
other questions
well if there are no other questions i
can continue with my questions
uh so actually another question was for
gopi nuts so
can you go back to your slides again
actually yes let me share your slides
yeah that would
be great so because there was a crucial
point when you got cut off like for the
second time
um so so sorry i missed actually the
notion of approximation you
talked about was it a multiplicative
approximation was it an additive
approximation
multiplicative approximation okay and uh
secondly
uh so you talked about a very basic uh
like you know i guess
binary relation estimating a very basic
binary relation
is there something like a one can ask
something similar
as a turn of evaluation like you know if
there was a hyper graph and you were
asking
how many three hyper monochromatic three
hyper wedges were there
yes that is a nice question but um
we tried but it needs more
thing to be handled in this stream
because handling nah insta object that
in streaming
estimating uh number of edges is direct
but the triangle problem even if on
colored version
is non-trivial i see so
colored version of triangle is uh maybe
our future work
but other even if we don't know if uh
what is a normal triangle counting
uh if it just are coming in random model
okay or
so even if on call of one colored person
in random stream are not
uh so well i was
i was i was thinking i was not actually
thinking about like you know
that you are given uh edges and you're
going to do triangle counting maybe
um maybe my question is not very
sensible but
uh uh the the question i was asking is
whether one can ask whether like you
know if you were getting hyper edges
as your input itself yes
then yeah yes so
suppose uh in that case also that is a
nice question but the difficulty
will be at this step that considered a
three uniform hypothesis
ubw uh here we are considering vertex
arrival model
so we get to know about this hyper edge
when the last vertex arrives
okay
to check whether this is monochromatic
we need the colors of
all three uh where the challenge lies
i see i see
[Music]
i had a general query with respect to
extending
uh these algorithms uh
uh to uh
function approximation
[Music]
settings for example if flying
uh some sort of uh uh
networks or uh deep uh
layers or uh hierarchical structures
and adding some kind of a
stochastic noise here for the sampling
so i was thinking more in terms of ml
and
how will that help uh
for the future
[Music]
generalizability if we look at from that
viewpoint yes
uh the algorithm can be adapted for
estimate number of a particular kind of
constrained
edges so colorful edges or suggesting
some kind of
color combination that the suppose we
are allowed
with some k colors and the color
difference will be something or
other that the difference would be large
or like for those setting this problem
can be
adapted uh but
adding noise i am not sure so whether
our technique can be adapted or not
but that will be a nice question to
study
good thanks
other questions
i i actually had one more question so
for passing
so uh uh uh so so sorry i'm not very
familiar with the like random graph
literature
but uh uh you like are there other
examples of other
like similar np-hard search problems
where on random graphs are sharp
thresholds are known and there are
efficient algorithms but not necessarily
linear time algorithms
like apart from hamiltonian cycle is
there something one can think about or
potentially apply your ideas
to other graph problems something like
that um
let me think
well so i mean
so there's like um approximations for
colorings and independent sets i mean
that would be like the natural np
complete problems i could think of but
they're actually not
i mean it's there it's harder to
estimate precisely
like what is the size of in or what is
exactly the callability
but it's very well known like some
ranges like that's very well studied
but um uh and there
i guess there exists some algorithms
which
also do some greedy type strategy and
then do some adjusting i would assume
that
yeah so i think they're not optimal yet
but they're also like the bounds are not
optimal yet so
um i guess that's always work and and
then i guess there's
um there's not or
i can think of another natural np
complete problem on graphs i guess
um i mean structural wise yeah
anything like the hamilton cycle um
may be not natural enough to i mean
they're
the humble cycle makes more sense i
would say
i guess because many uh random
[Music]
i guess for many uh and yeah i'm trying
to think because
many like constrained satisfaction
problems or something like that for
random
settings i guess the answer would
probably be like you know something
which concentrates around something and
just trying to think like what are the
search problems one can think about
but uh yeah i guess like hamiltonian
cycle
independence that isn't national yeah i
mean randomness
tends to always help a lot and this is
what
i've i've been able to learn but
trees also help here with respect to
randomizations
can you repeat the question uh the uh
avl trees
yes what yeah uh with
respect to those randomizations
so um i don't know so
do we use avl trees or uh
specifically with respect to those
randomizations as you said
uh uh in high dimensions so
was just just thinking if we apply that
data structure
uh those those trees that that might
help with respect to the fast
um matching and the search space
uh yes so we actually apply a variant of
adl trees
and they're i mean we don't necessarily
need the randomness but they help for
the
the storing of the hamiltonian path
if you mean that okay okay
so um uh story of the uh uh
haven't only possible then uh
we probably pro probabilistically uh
uh uh how how do i say it uh
uh complaints are is it
it is much more uh efficient with
respect to the other
things the other techniques that you
have tried
just to clarify from my perspective
um so uh
i'm not sure if i understand the
question so we also used avl trees and i
think they were a very natural data
structure to use
and um
[Music]
i mean yeah we didn't necessarily need
randomness for that
evil trees are a good tool in general i
think um there you have guaranteed
guaranteed amortized runtimes
independent of the input
thanks
uh are there any other questions
well if not then we can close this panel
discussion
so thank you once again to all the
speakers uh